ecuador declaró obligatoria la
vacunación contra el hobbit 19 es el
primer país de américa latina en imponer
la medida con más del 77 por ciento de
la población vacunada responde al avance
que se está viendo de la variante
omicron en europa sin embargo la medida
no contempla sanciones sino el veto a
participar en todo tipo de actividades
de ocio el ministerio de salud está
definiendo que la vacuna es obligatoria
debido a la situación epidemiológica y
al riesgo para toda la comunidad
mientras tanto la organización mundial
de la salud aprobó la primera vacuna
producida en américa latina' se trata
del preparado desarrollado por la
universidad de oxford ya astrazéneca
fabricado de manera conjunta entre
méxico y argentina y aunque ya se aplica
en algunos países esta aprobación
aumentará el acceso a vacunas existen
otras soluciones desarrolladas en la
región principalmente los inmunizantes
cubanos que aunque efectivos aún no han
recibido la luz verde de la o ms
y es que el aumento de vacunas permite
la aplicación de dosis de refuerzo chile
anunció la aplicación de la cuarta dosis
a mayores de 60 años y trabajadores de
la salud desde mediados del próximo mes
de febrero de 2022 es el segundo estado
en tomar esta medida después de israel y
una muestra del éxito de la vacunación
del país austral con el 91% de la
población adulta inoculada es decir
existe una memoria que puede ser
estimulada por un nuevo booster un nuevo
reforzamiento además chile también se
convirtió en el primer país de américa
latina en vacunar a animales con la
solución experimental del laboratorio y
pro x la campaña inició en el wind show
en santiago donde tres leones tres
tigres tres pumas y un orangután
recibieron una dosis de la solución
experimental